screen junkies central today's episode
is brought to you by t-mobile
the uncarrier high-five we're here live
in San Diego States make some noise
what's up Jackie so welcome to Street
Jackie Central special episode of SJ
universe I'm so excite because we have
the cast of Dirk Gently here the writers
creators this is going to be insane
before we go I just want to make sure
I've told you all if you don't know
we're having an amazing deal on screen
junkies plus where we have over 20 shows
every week so much content stuff from
Doug Benson Kevin Smith all of our
friends from TV flights so much stuff
today and this week you can get a deal
off an annual membership 50% off I
promise is the best deal you're going to
get go to screen junkies calm slash plus
offer code SJ central 16 go do it you're
not you're going to regret it and thank
you so much for coming this is the kind
of stuff you're going to see over it
plus more and more often how excited you
to meet these people are there any other
Douglas Adams fans in the house I love
these books I grew up with these books
these are why I do comedy I'm so stoked
to talk to these guys let's just bring
them out and nothing less talking guys
first up you know him he's been in here
a few times already I love them one of
my favorite writers it's max Ladd
was anyone here last night for what
happened I will talk about it look I am
still riding that crack hi I was
celebrating like an NBA player he saw me
I was so drunk I was like oh I movie
fights and girls were like what are you
talking about
Mac or create a writer show her all the
amazing things of Dirk Gently we're
talking all about it next up executive
producer Robert Cooper come on up man
thank you so much for joining us
great to meet you man have a seat the
man behind Stargate sg-1 Stargate
Atlantis and Stargate Universe come on I
next up he's your Dirk Gently mr. Samuel
Barnett whoo
ladies and gentlemen is a Samuel
Barnett's first ever comic-con next up
she plays a man died Dirk Gently I'm so
happy to have her Hannah Marx ladies and
gentlemen this is Hannah marks
first-ever comic-con give her a warm
welcome
and then she plays fair black ladies and
gentlemen Jada Shaq welcome ladies and
gentlemen this is Jada shets first-ever
comic-con warm Rado pleasure were all
about how many times in this next person
been a comic-con a lot I think he was
born here ladies and gentlemen
Elijah Wood
we've got some extra mics on this side
here I love it
thanks buddy guys this is amazing your
guys are here at proning I'm so excited
Joe over there amazing super fit as well
we are so excited William Joe's pan so
are we I'm now afraid so guys I mean
tell us cuz I know a lot of we have a
lot of Doug ascension and fans the book
and the novel and I want to start with
you sorta max because how did this
happen tell us about it give us the cell
like a like from day one the quick
version the quick version yeah I'm
possible I read Dirk gently's holistic
detective agency when I was 13 at summer
camp I actually read long dark teatime
at first at 13 this is going to be the
long version no no no meanwhile
meanwhile several years earlier a guy
named Arvin David read it in high school
and wanted to put on a play Douglas
Adams came to that play made a
friendship with Arvind David that led to
Arvind getting the rights they were
taken away from him BBC maybe Dirk
Gently that is sort of like the books
but there's no weird science fiction or
magic so when the rights went out when
that didn't get renewed Arvind knew to
call this guy because this guy loves
those books and he was like hey
max you seem really really depressed by
the studio system and really really
angry about everything and I was like yo
that's my brand dawg
and he was like you all do a TV show and
I was like no he was like do you want do
Dirk Gently as a TV show and I was like
yes and that's sort of where it started
and then Rob made it so that we could
actually make a real TV show because I
am an adult child that story actually
read like a dirt gently novel to in ways
a lot of tangential connections yeah
really true uh so uh Joe glad I know you
have a bunch of questions yeah okay so
um I'm a kid that uh
around 12 or 13 I read hitchhikers
changed my life uh max I know with
Victor you guys did you guys have any
like particular moment reading either
hitchhikers or dirt slike a passage or a
chapter in that book where you were like
the lights just clicked on and you were
like oh this like this - Zinn
you up I mean I know mine I know mine
real easy
it's the moment at the beginning of
hitchhikers the first time I ever read
it when he when the bulldozers coming to
wrack our third ends house is anybody
read Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy
and he lays down in front of the
bulldozer and the guys I believe they
take a lunch and then his friend Ford
shows up and the stakes of the book are
not clear
it's called Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy but it's about the demolition of
a house and you're like what the is
going on then his friend Ford Prefect
shows up and very casually says I'm an
alien
we should leave because this planet's
going to be destroyed about 15 minutes
so we should go Earth's over and just
from that kick point what bull's
narrative Lee to say Earth gets
destroyed in the first 30 of this book
and and it's not a big deal it's not the
point of the book the book is not about
the destruction of Earth that's a random
incident in the opening of the book
that's Douglas Adams in a nutshell
that's sick
it's a ridiculous laugh I apologize so
um
Douglas Adams himself he was he's pretty
adaptation friendly like I disagree
vehemently yeah well I mean asset actors
questions okay yeah we could do that so
so Dirk Gently is a guy who I mean this
is guy who in one of his books his arc
is overcoming a conflict with his
refrigerator how how do you portray that
guy on on screen
oh um describe describe our Dirk
odd duck is um kind of insane I mean he
really really really doesn't know what
he's doing and he he would die probably
about 20 times in the first episode if
he didn't meet Todd so Dirk has this
kind of intuition and kind of hunch
about the universe and and the way
things work and he can see connections
between things that other people can't
see but actually that makes his life
really quite lonely and lonesome and
he's it's that thing he's actually just
looking for a friend and toddies going
to be his friend he
assist friend whether he likes it or not
mostly whether or not yeah yeah but it's
a bromance via hijacking yeah
our show could be compared to Sherlock
and Watson if Sherlock kidnapped Watson
and forced him to do everything yeah I
mean it's not it's certainly not a
literal translation George you know
Douglas Adams is kind of a you know
philosophical orgy of the absurd and you
know I think max has done a brilliant
job of capturing that spirit but I think
our show is much more at least the the
entrance to the show is much more
grounded much more real a larger plays a
character named Todd who is you know
could be you could be your neighbor you
know and and he's the one who kind of
leads us into that world and neighbor is
an a lovable
and and you know Dirk just kind of drops
into his life and Dirk is that sort of
magical character and that sort of lifts
the veil and and introduces us to those
more you know incredible aspects to the
to the to the story you know the new
Ghostbusters movie isn't really
ghostbusters but it's ghostbusters and
the real sequel to Ghostbusters is the
movie the frighteners you know what I
mean
a man by the way uh hit the frighteners
you guys are underappreciated film this
is this is to the books as the
frighteners is to ghostbusters I'll take
that that's good Elijah I'm curious
because you always pull only put picks
sort of projects you're really
passionate about like you Wilford all
these amazing things you've done like
what what was it about this one date
that was important for you because this
heats characters not in the book
immigrant novels in stuff like what what
what struck you honestly it was it was
the pilot script I read the script kind
of reluctantly because I was like ahhhh
cuz max's name was on it oh no i mean
i'm not at all about at all
i was excited to read it cuz max wrote
it but i was only their cyborg superman
but I was also like it's a television
show and it's a lot it could be a
potentially long come
then in but I read it and I literally
had one of those moments I finished the
the script put it down and I was like
it's so good I fell in love with it
it was one of those things that was
completely undeniable I'd never read
anything like it um it's completely
batshit crazy in the best way you you
the first episode sets up these things
but you don't quite know what they mean
and you won't know what they mean
necessarily for a little while but it's
it's so difficult to describe
and yet you know at the center of it
it's at the core of the story is this
guy who's had this sort of you know
awful day and he meets this detective or
this person who says he's a detective
and they sort of set forth on this
insane journey and I just I don't know
I've never read anything like it and I
just wanted to be a part of it it was
really exciting Hannah Jane what about
you two like what was a n Samuel will
get you but uh was there anything
because your characters also sort of
renewer like how did you yeah
when I read the pilot I also like there
was definitely at least two or three
moments where I had to stop I was
laughing so hard that I had to I had to
look like a tenant and no mass prior to
that so I had to google him and find out
don't Google me and one week later one
viewing of wrestling is a wrestling
later yeah it was just so funny and had
so much heart and even yeah my character
is not in the book but yeah the the
character that he puts on the page is so
dynamic and so just full of heart and
exciting and funny and weird and erotic
and badass all of these things one of
the fun things about the pilot is that
there are like five or six different
storylines that are that are set up and
you meet these characters who in and of
themselves could be the stars of their
own show and and they seem completely
separate and yet by the end of the
season they will all come together in a
way that is hopefully hopefully
satisfying like Big Lebowski as Game of
Thrones like Hannah and Jayde both play
characters who really are kind of the
star
of their own storylines for me I I get
to play the drums and I have
hallucinations and I'm a agoraphobic and
I've got a lot going on I have some
friends named the rowdy three there are
four of them
they destroy everything their scenes are
so fun to watch and so hard to shoot
show up on set and just smash for
four hours it's for Canadian actors we
were like hey guys you want to just
break everything and they were like yes
and then they apologize we're so sorry
sick so I figured like what other chance
am I gonna have to get to do something
like this plus max wrote it and it's
incredible Sammy what about you and I
how about like derping where how does
his detective nough scared to say Batman
or Sherlock oh no I mean well that there
is no comparison
I mean if Sherlock is all logic then
Dirk is all instinct and heart and gut
reaction and intuition and chaos Dirk is
total chaos so in the show things that
there's like there's no fat in the show
at all every single scene is completely
necessary and you'll be watching it
going how does that tie in stuff from
episode 8 you'll look back to episode 1
and see where it came from
it's that kind of show and and I think
people will get a lot of there's a lot
of ways of watching this show you can
just kind of let it wash over you and it
will come to the conclusion you will be
kind of carried along and you won't feel
like you're completely lost or you can
watch it picking up on every clue and
every Easter Egg that's in there and
it's it's going to be very satisfying on
loads of levels I think yeah the first
season is one story and that wraps up
perfectly and what you're protective if
it didn't switch characters how
satisfying was it so this is eight
episodes and how satisfying was it to to
just be able to set out tell one story I
chose the hardest story possible because
this is dirt gentle absolute
we're dealing with a level of plot
contrivance and convolution that is so
beyond unnecessary it takes like if you
watch the show you'll get it but I
remember when Elijah got it I remember
when Rob got it has everybody figured
out how the mystery works in the first
season like I hate the fact that
everybody now says oh man is gonna make
you head explode like that's become a
cliche no no really you know I'm gonna
you no other way
there's no other way to describe this
your head will explode first blood will
come out of your ears and then it will
just literally spray on the walls what I
love it too is that max is literally
breaking all the rules of screenwriting
in this like the way those it rules but
the things that you're supposed to do
which is like basically filter
information based on something that
you've set up he doesn't do that he
completely eludes you and which is very
much like Dirk you are Dirk as a writer
and you're prevent you're sort of
presenting the viewers with a very
unsafe and um you know it's an untrodden
ground that the people are gonna be
constantly questioning where they are at
any given time which is you will be in
tanjur while you're well you are gonna
be in danger all I care about is that
you like the characters and you want to
see what happens to them you can I just
say that a corgi is a lead role yeah
corgi is a lead role in the show
yeah you guys are selling this hard I'm
very excited who's excited I am right
max I know we're a big fan of you you've
been helpful in our show he crushed her
on movie fights last night's coming back
Elijah you have as well thank you I want
to see you two go head-to-head oh I just
annihilated nine people in a row violate
me that's the only thing I don't know if
I want to go against you you're so sweet
though I might you know I might I might
go to the audience thumbs up thumbs down
as to whether or not I annihilate you
but I like gladiator style but I'm so
grateful you all guys came here and
thank you so much for doing this we're
so excited
no BBC coming up at this fall this fall
right October 22nd BBC America we love
screen junkies we're so psyched we
love screen jockeys we long
words not listening you're watching me
him/her on Netflix brother but we got to
wrap you guys up and I want to thank you
guys let's give him a big round of
applause thanks y'all Derek Campbell
thank you
and then guys thanks again to sponsor
t-mobile with double the LTE coverage
get your screen junkies fix and more
places to watch our previous show click
to the left and to view everything else
from screen junkie central click to the
right
you